oh shirt
terrifying
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Callisto protocol
S I had to rewatch you that because
apparently it saved before and
apparently exited the game before that
um but he's not dead there's no way that
he's not dead there's no way that he is
dead
come on okay where's the uh
outside the Gatehouse
every time
okay so this Warden is apparently new
this Warden spouts a lot of prophetic
style teachings
I saw the marker for a second there hi
who's growling
uh yeah that's
yeah that's me okay should I be worried
about this
I'm assuming this is sound proving and
not horrible death machines
I go in good s good yes good
aftermath
where were we in the pre-math before I
mean clearly this is the aftermath of
something happening
and you know as much as I would like to
give him Credence that it may be just a
coincidence that I crash landed here and
all of it went to [ __ ] and this new
Warden problem
what is required
to make the hard choices
as your new Warden I will do what is
necessary
for this storage Institution
for the good of all mankind
imagine you were working in a company
and your boss comes in and starts
talking like that you know something
bad's about to happen no one talks like
that
well I mean some people talk like that
but no one up to any kind of good talk
like that hi hey what's up Al he looking
good you've been working out hey how's
that piano recital
hey see it finger plane
finger painting plastic oh hey whoa hey
no you don't
yeah
okay well this barely does more
okay you bear you don't even really have
arms left
okay okay I'm starting to get a hang of
that combat mechanic I do like it I
think it's interesting at first I was
like wary of it but now that I'm
starting to get a feel of it it does
feel more flowy
feels good actually
it's refreshing
I'm not sure if I should be drinking the
blood of my enemies at this moment
because of the possibility of infection
but I just can't stop myself I Relish in
the art of combat hello where am I going
uh
uh I saw a light there which oh no
shimmy I forgot my my various very
special moves also there's been two
patches since I played and seems like a
lot of the performance issues have
have uh
gotten better
well done I thought you'd be dead by now
agree with that finally someone with a
good idea
yeah
this way
yeah that way okay
all right
not sure what that gel hold on we got
delightful lockers here that I'm gonna
raid this is very important the credits
God if we're gonna get out of here alive
we might as well have some money
shimmy
did you do your shimmy training
this will come in handy though
take that over to the reforge you can
use it to print a new weapon
give me a minute to tap into the system
I see he's given me the weapon because
he's about to die
I don't even know what a reforge is but
it sounds pretty cool
all this futuristic attack can be opened
with just a shiv
I'd like to think that Humanity really
isn't that different United day
have a unite
I'm not gonna read too much into it why
did he rip off the top of the perfectly
good gun and give me the shitty bass
level stuff I'm assuming anyway okay
hand cannon that's basically all I can
do at this point all right
is progress
okay God damn if that's actually the
future
that's crazy I'm not talking just for
guns but for anything a 3D printing does
get that fast
getting in there
yeah ever since I got it yeah they can
scramble your brains a little bit don't
worry you get used to it I sure know a
lot about this place
yeah I've had nothing but time okay so
what's next the shoe
can we just watch our way in there no I
wish we could it's not gonna be that
easy bro I've been here a long time I've
got privileges that you've done it so
I'm gonna have to take you a different
way but I'll be your eyes and ears and
I'll guide you along no don't you leave
me hanging I've got you unless you know
I'm part of it
I'm afraid not I'll get that door for
you he's a pilot was that news that was
shared before because I don't remember
that my pilot friend friend died
tragically just as I arrived here we
were aborted by Pirates it was really
cool very swashbuckling I didn't hide I
confronted them
oh strategic targeting system after
performing a melee combo Tech look for
the quick shot indicator press and hold
the right Mouse button then quickly
press the left to automatically lock on
and Fire
okay I'm gonna screw that up God I'm
gonna screw that up who wants some
come get some
oh no
um
okay
Oh no I got this
mono imano I got this there we go I
don't need your hint yep
I don't see any quick hit indicator
are you really active oh there it was
okay so technically it could come in the
middle of a two hit combo I've done
three hits before at times but really
it's like gauging
I got elephant
it's kind of got blood all over me I
kind of I kind of got everywhere and
things that don't look like blood should
I be worried about any of that probably
not it's it's probably definitely fine
what is this three rounds one squeeze
sure is that necessary I don't know is
it
wasn't there a gun prototype way long
ago well not way long ago but way long
ago in current Internet years it was
like it was a grid of like 10 by 10
barrels and they just fired 100 bullets
all at once wasn't that a thing I never
heard anything else about it so I'm
guessing it wasn't exactly practical
just a wall of projectile
might as well just throw some saw blades
Dead Space style
but uh I'm sure it had limited case uses
and it's behind me
now see that
that's spooky
I got a good feeling about this
if I go into every situation oh wow
he's just looking at the Pretty Lights
can I crouch away from this is stealth
an even an option in this game what
happens if I sneak up on him
oh
oh
quick kill I like that I like I should
turn off my flashlight but whatever
yeah make sure you get the blood in your
teeth
quick soup delivery
uh clean up spillages
a few stutters here and there still
which is but it's a lot better than it
was so I'm not gonna oh that's not good
I don't know if I I'm hmm uh I think it
sees me
oh it sees me oh it sees me all right oh
it sees me oh
oh it'll never find me
it'll never find me oh it'll never find
me I should turn my flashlight off nope
that ain't happening
oh it's Twitchy
oh it's Twitchy all right oh
it'll never find me
I'm not gonna find me
oh
it's not gonna find me
good turner oh it's coming around
oh it's Twitchy you gotta keep going
buddy oh yeah you are oh yeah you are oh
this is what I was meant to do oh I got
a bad feeling I got a good feeling about
this I got a good feeling about this I
bet I can insta kill you
certainly oh I can't I'm just staring at
your ass great ass great ass great ass
I guess I can't kill that thing
I thought I could kill that thing oh do
I kill it do I shoot it can I kill it I
feel like it's really bad to fight that
thing something about that tells me that
it's no good to fight that thing
I don't think I have enough bullets I
don't think I have any bullets I don't I
I got a gun I got no guarantee that I
have bullets do I have bullets six I
have Six Bullets
that's right put it away pal
okay I'm gonna go for it
everybody hold on to your butts I'm
going for it I'm going in here
good thing you can't see Shadows
oh my God it was a pathway over there oh
supposed to go that way
you coming back oh no you're not yes you
are oh you're twitching
oh God
that's an explodey that's good to know
oh
[Music]
what is the deal
when did this game get super spook
oh I don't like any of this
all right probably okay for the time
being
hand Cannon ammo
okay good we didn't even we didn't even
dick around with a regular pistol we
went straight for hand Cannon
so can I Vault over this
uh not what I wanted there we go
I feel better also why was it why were
there bullets in a prison cell
I thought this was supposed to be
maximum security it doesn't feel very
maximum
or secure
for that matter
okay down I go I think
well that was terrifying
it's probably not over but I didn't like
that thing
I didn't want to fight that thing I
would never want to fight that thing
oh so calm
well
good thing there's blood here too
wouldn't want to miss out on that
wouldn't want to feel like
not at home
Ste all right
good God
I swear
this game got spooky
I love it though
and I hate it I love that I hate it I
hate love it where did the thing that I
heard go
well it's probably not gonna pop out of
me at a random Place definitely not
gonna do that oh shirt
you're fine
oh no you did the thing I knew you were
hey whoa hey whoa hey
Milo
two one
oh but I had my oh I was ready for the
Dodge
uh nope
oh whoa whoa whoa oh okay you actually
you have to oh you have to
okay you have to uh you're still alive
how are you still alive
I don't understand how you're alive but
do I have any health I do God okay so
headshots don't guarantee anything just
like dead space I suppose well anyway
I was just goofing about this being
spooky this isn't scary at all
huh
okay we got a vent over there oh oh I
thought I saw something
why are there just clothes lying around
did everyone mutate and just explode
right out of their clothes or uh am I
reading too much into that
no or don't do that I'm going for it let
me reload
sure hope nothing sneaks out behind me
these guys are surprisingly stealthy
nice
how nice nice I still don't know what
the energy converter does but
all right
if and you say so I'll go in the spooky
hole
I hate it hate it hate it hate it hate
it hate it
hate it
hate it you know I might have been
critical about the crawling animation in
the last one now and that I know they're
probably just gonna use that in multiple
places
I forget what the mantle oh it's e is is
everything I do think that was uh
uncomfortable
in a good way for a horror game in a bad
way for everything else in my life
hello
oh I'm back
did I need to go there
are you gone
oh
good all of this is so good
I'm gonna ignore the groaning
you gone buddy
better be gone oh my God are you gone oh
maybe it was my gamer Instinct that told
me that that thing was extremely
dangerous
but also maybe I could have killed it
and I seemed like a coward right now but
I know I'm not
for some reason and it's probably my
gamer Instinct because I am gamer of the
Year officially proven but uh I thought
it would kill me
in fact I was almost positive it would
kill me
hey
frick frack frack
gamer instinct is telling me something
it's more just like if I were to make
this game I would put a scare right here
but maybe that's just throwing me off oh
I knew it
oh no that's not that bad
yeah whatever
but what is the weird Robo thing I'm
hearing
oh it's that it's uh it's I'm out in the
open I'm very out and very open and that
thing doesn't look too terribly damaged
all right Buddies
let's play a little game the game is
called I'm gonna stab you in the brain
it's a very fun game
you can tell your friends about it oh
don't go I'm so crouched there's no way
you could possibly see me
how is this a thing
wait no
oh okay oh boy
oh there we go well okay you're your
your brain's gone
whoa
[Music]
come on do it
stop
okay starting to get a read on these
things
I forgot to Stomp The oh I forgot to be
Stompy I haven't been stomping but I am
getting better at reading them so you
just gotta wait to see if they're gonna
attack twice before you do anything else
but if you see an opportunity you know
you really got to take it when you have
it and definitely don't waste bullets
probably I'm just guessing that this is
how it's gonna be don't waste bullets
trying to shoot everything unless you're
in a stressful situation that's when you
want to save your bullets for this is
again gamer of the Year Markiplier is
telling you the most amazing advice
you'd ever hear I hope everyone is
writing this down and not writing snarky
passive aggressive comments
in the comments
any dead guards you say
oh no
so is that thing going to be pissed if I
uh steal something from a guard
failure
yeah you
oh no this ain't gonna be good is it
I got a bad feeling about this
I don't want to
oh no
yeah don't look at what you're doing
[Applause]
uh-huh
Eric Jane
okay
well you stay right there pal I'm just
gonna quickly give this an old
key code hint maintenance Bay has been
removed from security all credentials
will now be hard-coded to civilian
issued implants
I had to feel
it
my tower
what's happening
and
yeah okay who talks like that who who
puts someone in charge that talks like
that
it's only concerning I only have
concerns
certainly it wasn't built to last
absolutely not why would it have been
it's a prison
a few people got raptured right out of
their pants
hello
who's there oh
huh I shouldn't be worried about that no
way they can break out what are these
supposed to be body bags laundry is this
laundry it better be laundry
oh my God this better be laundry hi how
you doing good to meet you
hey what's up
hey don't do that
take that
oh yeah
oh man my game room stinks are at
maximum
oh
and for good measure
what next anyone else wanna come at me I
really am starting to enjoy the combat I
think that there's it's it's not quite
like anything I've ever experienced
before it's not timing
how are you doing buddy
you're making blood angels oh wow you
keep it up value
you keep it up uh it's not quite like
anything I've I've ex nope okay no way
how about I go this way yeah you know
what how about this way
you know what um
interestingly enough I hate both ways
but I hate this marginally less
yeah where everything I'm used to in
games are timing bases like oh you got
to be the quick reaction but having
something to hold there and it's kind of
like you're you're waiting the reaction
is on your action instead of what
they're doing
or opportunities it is focused very much
on what they're doing I don't know how
to put that right uh Lexi and make it
seem like I'm actually deserving of
being gamer gamer of the year game gamer
of the year uh oh
lexian did you do that
no okay
hey stop that
hey no oh what the hell I dodged oh
maybe that was the same direction
oh you're going for a backswing
that's what I thought
you gurgly [ __ ]
all right so I took it there but that's
not too bad I just gotta remember to
always alternate because otherwise I am
going to get caught sometimes or maybe I
like uh the combo I shouldn't have tried
to do two for some reason it did kind of
feel late on that one there's probably
some nuances to the combat that I still
got to figure out but it's all feel
based and I think that's pretty cool
I'm eating I I know how to open doors
again
no I'm really on for it
that was a level two e door oh good
man if there's one thing this game gets
right it's ominous glows
there sure are some excellent ominous
glows
okay
I'll take this
I don't think he told me to do this I
think I'm just doing it
Dr Hayes huh
you
um
we have to fight more
the hell is she
I don't know I don't even know who
Mueller is I probably do know who Muller
is but I don't know right now
and apparently the warden wanted this
well hi
all right then
well apparently the warden wanted this
and I'm part of it somehow well probably
not part of it but whatever I was uh
whatever I was carrying in our ship
that's what was part of it
uh-huh
so yeah knock knock who's there
are fine and
anyway
some kind of contagious material or bio
weapon or whatever have you
because in the opening cut scene
it seemed like people were getting
infected but they weren't turning into
anything at that moment do I get one of
them
do I get I'm I imagine it's powered by
anger
is it like the Kinesis module
yeah I imagine it's rage powered just
based on what the the other dude was
doing
oh hell yeah give me this
[Music]
grab objects
ah oh
oh who wants a can of coffee Wham
all right oh okay
so they were studying something let's
see if we can glean anything from the
medical mumbo jumbo
all right okay let's see what do we got
here um seems like well oh was that a
door squeak
did I
am I crazy Dodge
I just hear a door squeak okay we got
some kind of
uh
I I I it's an eye it's an i it's an i i
and then I don't know what that is nose
Maybe
something was infecting people right
before the breakout huh
okay well that's a perfectly ordinary
looking heart in a perfectly unordinary
looking chest ah everyone knows what
that that is
everyone knows what that is
everyone knows we all know we don't need
to tell say it out loud we don't say it
out loud actually so
if you don't know don't ask
hi welcome to the party oh let me just
okay I'm doing it I'm whoa slow motion
hey what's up
uh did that do anything for me
what was the point of that
come on
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey big
guy big guy hey whoa what's up what's up
hey don't do that
you know I thought this would be a
little bit better of a weapon
man he's kind of tough for this guy why
oh two for one
oh god oh owie owie hey hey
can this guy be dead please neither of
them are dead what was that
oh I feel amazing oh I'm dead I don't
feel uh whatever I did was so cool
though
oh wow
you were yanking on my lower John
Suddenly my whole
oh this went away whatever I did was
super cool but it's like I couldn't turn
around and face the other guy quick
enough
do I have any what's my inventory what
is this
oh that must be what for the energy
what's not what's knots and what's what
is with was yeah that thing oh I gotta
go all the way through this again and
what am I supposed to do when I grab
them
come on
whoa hey okay you came out of nowhere
all right you know for a big guy you're
kind of quick
are you dead no it's
awfully interesting of you not to be
dead
how
oh
I hope I have a medical thing nope uh
hey a medical thing
okay I don't see where or if there was
another guy it's like he just didn't
spawn I could have taken both of them if
that one didn't just surprise me out of
nowhere
oh that looks more than just God that
looks fried
I probably have an extra yes I do
good
[Music]
hello
wookie
[Applause]
okay I thought I went the sideway no I
didn't know if I went the right way or
not I never know if I'm going the right
way I don't know where the right way is
oh hello oh I must have been missing
those
ah with all the other Pretty Lights here
I didn't know that there was anything
what am I inventory full is it
is it I guess I should use the health
thing
[Music]
I might as well I was at like half
and I'm not gonna get hit anymore so I
don't need to worry about
[Music]
okay all right
you got it
upgrady something or other
way
all right it's good stuff
okay
Lottery
ah cell what can I sell uh these things
I don't know what it is but I don't need
three of them for sure it's ten bucks
it's it's really worth it why is this
one too pristine energy okay I'll keep
that one just for the space and then
I'll uh it's not even worth selling
really unlocks a new heavier attack ooh
increases the length of an officer's
melee combo
does it I like heavy I think
foreign
I can almost have another one if I were
to sacrifice some bullets for the gun or
the the not bullet thing might be pretty
cool I don't really block much so I
might as well just do this
get more combos because it really is
just more than when I'm fighting more
than let's say two that's the problem so
I need the heavy attack and then I need
to be able to finish things off quicker
so let's go for that all right thank you
I'm happy
what madman would sell bullets for
more sortiness press middle Mouse button
to perform a male heavy melee heavy have
longer windup cause more damage can hit
multiple enemies and knock them back
much farther so conditionally I'm very
much turning this into Eldon ring what
do we got here
that's not bad okay I can time that up
your batter's up
I'm ready good thing I went that way or
else I would never gotten all that stuff
who wants some anybody I'll take on
anybody literally anybody
I don't care if you're an innocent
civilian I need to use my heavy attack
yes thank you
that's a good sight that's what you want
to see that's comforting oh yeah
oh okay good stuff um why why why
oh no they hung up by their own entrails
or those bed sheets
um yeah I actually agree with that I
agree with that maybe you should
yeah uh-huh
I'm quick and efficient about that well
time to listen to a story
yeah okay all right there
all right good story glad I listened to
that that really uh helped me in my
situation
pertinent to my survival
I just realized I could probably have
been stomping those this whole time and
I haven't been
I've seen many of those
well
no spilled milk tears or whatever it is
I think that's the same
sodi
shimmy
busted
inside
I just want that given that I've seen
elevators go
oh no
good Elias
what wow
do I gotta press e on this oh never mind
yeah
barely
figure
out
another elevator can't wait yeah good
stuff
um why am I alive
oh God damn it
oh boy hey oh God why in the world is
that I thought it was a baby
what the hell
am I okay
am I am I okay
am I all right
am I okay
I don't know how you had credits in you
whoa
who watch out I've got a heavy attack
what happened
oh my god oh wow I love that
hey I dodged that
oh
my final swing ain't swinging as good as
it should stop moving stop it
it's not a swinging as as good as it
should swung you know it's uh as I'm
getting used to
I have no Health well it's okay I don't
need it I'm a badass as you can see
clearly
very very cool it's stuffing things
anyway the power situation right right
that's good yes
um
I might die
but then again I might not die
which is preferable
nice I knew it I suspected a gamer
Instinct Lucy make me look cool in this
moment I feel like I don't look cool I
feel like I'm very uncool you know what
I mean
okay thank you whatever you did is
amazing stop it watch this oh hey that
was perfectly timed that actually was I
feel like anyway
I feel like that was perfectly timed but
whatever we don't care about timing
foreign
good God I need help
I do like the heavy swing it is pretty
cool
I feel like if I push something into
that it'll die
I also feel like I'm dying wait a minute
that's a health thing
[Music]
oh no no baby no no don't do it oh God
is that the thing oh that's the thing
isn't it oh that's the thing oh it's the
thing oh it's the thing
oh it's the thing it's so the thing oh
it's the thing
oh my god well I'm gonna heal
yeah scream yeah okay it's fine it's
fine it's fine
things are awful every way awful awful
stop being awful
you're the worst
yeah
if there was a health item that came out
of that thing I don't even know if I'd
want it I don't know if anybody should
want it okay is that thing still here is
that thing still here
you still here thing
you still here I ain't afraid of you I
ain't
I ain't I am I'm not
I hear something stamping around
whoa hey whoa oh okay all right
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah that's what you get
nice
I think the rainbow is heavy because I I
swear I did a heavy attack and rainbows
shot out everywhere so I assume that's
good
[Music]
see that's nice
this nice nice nice nice what I did
there nice Cara Brown nice
nice
nice
the high value Asset transferred at 0315
restrict area to clearance level Zeta
okay well no audio log so I'm not
interested
all right let's see what's going on over
here I know you're over there oops
good thing I'm hidden in this light
do I gotta sneak by
foreign
that is a problem so can I kill this
thing maybe I should just sneak by maybe
maybe I should just sneak by maybe okay
or I'll thump right down don't do it
uh
hey wait a minute okay oops oh this is
bad
nice
get down
ow
how are you still alive
okay Al ow stop that
okay oh boy
yay
oh is that necessary
okay this thing
oh there's two of them
what
I I swear it was a batter of up
situation
I swear it was so you can kill them
though and they don't just insta-kill
you but there was also two of them which
is a problem all right let me show you
how
I will expertly handle this situation
okay
well I've alerted them to my presence
because as you can see is part of the
strategy all right
yoink
he'll never know what hit him
and now I've neutralized its ability to
spit
which leaves Me Only With The lethality
of my weapons okay
oh yes please
yeah yeah
okay you block I don't like the blocking
oh yeah that's what you get oh what oh
no it's the thing e
w
ew ew whoa God oh interesting so that
one's dead now oh
ah
you still have a head I don't like that
yeah yeah yeah try it see what happens
to you you blocked it see that's what
happened to you
go lay down oh God nope not today okay
again with the sweet blocks
you guys really good at the blocking
thing
okay and again with the hmm
there we go
oh oh maybe I can batter it up into the
oh
yeah come at me oh yeah yeah come at me
come at me this way Orient yourself okay
never mind I'm dead
okay all right let's see and get to the
point where I win
yes
don't that's incredible
come here come here try me
don't do nothing
oh yes yes yes
oh my God
oh yes give me the health injector yes
yes
heavy attack was a good idea everybody
heavy attack was a very very good idea
let me finish off the rest of these
bozos suppose I could try to stealth
kill him
again not stealthy
oh that's nice
hey bud what's up
[Applause]
oh interesting I don't know what to do
about that
interesting
all right I win
I am amazing
uh what did I win live won nothing
no I won nothing what did I wait did I
come here
uh oh nope yes yes
but wasn't there another fuse behind
unless it's just returned do I have a
map in any way do I have any kind of a
map
I don't do I
shoe access
I guess I could see what it is I could
have sworn there was a different ones
though
is this really where I want to go
you're not with them what's in there oh
my God
the only reason I'm doing this is
because I I could have sworn that there
was another fuse spot before and I'm
wondering if I go back am I gonna get
some goodies
there was there was another one storage
I get to go to storage I get goodies oh
give me the goodies oh oh what goodies
do I get
oh yes please
I knew it I knew it I knew it
I knew it I knew that that was right
what is this skunk gun
I don't know what that is but I love it
energy converter I already have that oh
really I only have one of these bullets
so
when anything need to be shot bang all
right
I've made space all right that's all I
need right there's no way to get back
through here all right around the other
way
okey-dokey then this was worth it
whatever a skunk gun is it probably is
pretty good okay also I don't know what
the utility of having Spike walls is but
I feel uh really gracious for that
and to have that around I really
appreciate that okay
and with that unfortunately
I'm out of time I'll leave you with this
ominous looking hallway oh no what's
that the end of the hallway I couldn't
be oh